So given that there are N processors participating
in a barrier algorithm, particularly dissemination barrier algorithm, how
many rounds do you think the dissemination barrier
algorithm needs to complete in order to know that
the barrier is done? So how many rounds
for the barrier completion? So the choices I'm giving
you: it's N log N, a log N to the base 2, Or feeling of log and
base, to the base 2, or N where N is of course a
number of processors that are participating in
this barrier. A hint for you [LAUGH]
I told you already that N in a dissemination barrier need not be a
power of 2. So that's a hint for you to, to answer this question.